ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon ukrainian special today uh we
were going to have a great journalist
mark galiotti from
london who writes about putin and russia
on but he is briefing the military
uh and cannot make it so i
with comparatively far less knowledge
about said issues are going to speak for
the hour
um we were trying to get an expert we
will potentially get him at a later date
we've had him on the show before
he wrote a book called the vori
russia's super mafia he also wrote a
book called what the west gets wrong
about putin
and he is one of the preeminent
journalists that has expertise in that
region that area we don't have them
couldn't get him
wanted to get him are trying to get him
right
and hopefully one day we'll get him
before putin gets them
um
very sad
what's happening in the ukraine if
you're a human being
if the internet has not
taken your humanity and it's taken many
of your humanity
um
if your personal brand has not eaten you
alive and it has for many of you
uh if your griff
knows no
bounds
um
no matter what you think about nato
expansion
or u.s imperialism
or whatever
the cia's misdeeds
the deep state
the chronicles of narnia
the teachers union
whatever
whatever
you still have to say seeing babies
being moved from like an icu
to like a subway tunnel
is um
sad it's a tragedy it's a human
tragedy has all war is right
uh it's not something to celebrate it's
not something to say this is cool
we enjoy this
[ __ ] around and find out look putin look
at this
that's not the take
if you're a
human
being
now the vast majority of people on this
uh platform aren't are not human that's
the point of the internet it's to make
you less human
and it's working very well
kudos
to the designers of that
because what it does is it you you watch
tragedies all day and you have no
you get desensitized to it
every day
from uh walmart fights to car crashes
to beheadings
all day every day it's in your face and
you forget that
those are people
and there are children you know you see
these waffle house brawls there's kids
sitting there
while their parents beat the [ __ ] sure
it's a goof
and it's fun
but then you go man i wonder what the
kids life's gonna be like
probably not great but again you can't
you can't dissect every waffle house
video and get in the weeds and start
worrying about
the second generation
um
but you should at the very least
look at an invasion of a country
by uh a dictator which is what putin is
he's a dictator
you know he invaded a sovereign country
and there's a lot of mayhem
and death
and carnage that you're gonna see
and the ukrainian people
uh are brave and they're fighting back
and they give a [ __ ] you know unlike
people in america who don't care about
much
other than themselves and their ability
to consume
other countries have deep and complex
histories
and they care about more than their
ability to go to a buffalo wild wings
we do not that is not part of our thing
here
um
so it's sad to watch all this [ __ ]
unfold and
yeah i mean just to give everyone a
little backstory
the ukraine
uh if you're if you're if you're not
aware of what's happening has been
invaded by russia
we'll start there
and the goal of that invasion is regime
change of course ukraine part of the old
uh soviet union
nato um
kind of the post-cold war architecture
of
how the world is going to run these um
you know trade alliances
military alliances
um
expanding nato into the region
uh where russia is
arming ukraine
funding ukraine
potentially admitting them to nato the
the discussion of that
um was not a good geopolitical move it
kind of put russia in a box
russia then reacted
um
in the way that russia a lot of people
feared that russia was going to react
which was to then take back
the territory that they feel is
rightfully
um
and you can have those conversations and
talk about
those are facts
um how much of that led to this decision
is uh we don't know you don't you're not
there i'm sure it didn't help
but
the idea here the takeaway is not
putin's cool
that shouldn't be the takeaway if you
are
a human being
this is not a cool thing to do
it's a brazen
you know criminal act
where you have somebody
going into a country decapitating the
leadership attempting to
um
bombing uh people murdering civilians
not good when we do it
wasn't right when america's done it
not right when we went into iraq or
afghanistan
stayed there for 20 years
that misadventure in the middle east
where we were
it's not
no it's not right
when when it's done
by anybody
but it's not cool
i know that a lot of people think it's
cool
and
badass to do
you know
this is people are happy about this
people's lives in this country have
gotten to the point
where they are happy
that this is happening and they're like
well it's because the american military
they're too focused on uh trans people
and
being a politically correct that's why
is that why it's happening
do you think putin really is convinced
that the american military is just like
uh
some type of
you know
i don't know extension of the lgbtq
whatever community do you think that's
what the intel and russia is telling
them
do you think they're go i mean it's it's
a very stupid way to look at things
that because the military is struggling
with whatever type of
i trans issues that affect this very
small percentage of the military i think
they're still focused on the amount of
funding it gets
how big it is
it's ability it's positioning all over
the world i you know i don't think putin
is uh
invading the ukraine he's not worried
about america because uh we're talking
about trans people that's why he that's
why he's doing it
uh no he's doing it he has more nuclear
warheads than any other country in the
world and what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do
if we were all christian
theocratic psychopaths
who burned gay people at the stake which
is what these people want
you think putin would be like oh [ __ ] it
i'm i like hey i'm not invading ukraine
i'm not doing it now
now i'm not doing it
no they they passed a don't say gay bill
in florida i'm not invading
i don't even want ukraine anymore my
main goal was that florida teachers had
to out kids as gay within six weeks
um that's why no i'm not due i don't
even i don't have any reason to go into
ukraine now they've just passed a law in
america he convenes everybody they all
they're all in moscow he goes saint
peter's but we're ever here uh hey guys
they just passed a law
that biological born males cannot
compete in female sports do you know
what that means no ukraine
no we're not gonna do it
because now i'm afraid of them
now i fear them
i know i have all the nukes but their
moral certitude
scares me
i'm scared by that
that terrifies me
see before when they were talking about
trans people and letting
trans people swim
i knew they were weak
but
when they flipped it
when they flipped it and went back to
those 19 because if you remember when we
had all those 1950s values we had no
problems with russia
you remember that
no we didn't have any these are all new
problems we never had
when back before they were trans people
or gay people
there was never any issues with ever
ever
this is all new
in the 50s and 60s you know when
everybody was like eating burgers and
smoking cigarettes and wearing jeans and
they were all at the hop
everybody was driving uh 57 chevys and
gay people had to shut up and black
people had to shut up and trans people
to shut up russia
loved us
we were like [ __ ] like this i mean
so this is the result of that it's the
result of that it's because that guy
made a dumb video with biden which i
think is a dumb video but that uh bonito
whatever on your uh instagram made some
video with buying and people going this
is why
putin didn't worry about taking the
ukraine it's like putin's never worried
about
taking the ukraine he's never worried
about it
there's nothing to do with our content
trust me
putin is not watching our content
it's but again it's silly
and these are
silly times for people
and i'm not saying we we are going over
there and fighting it's not our thing
it's not our war
this is not something where we should be
involved everybody who's going no-fly
zones he must pay he must pay
what
we're not in the position
to go and fight russia over the ukraine
we have military supremacy if we had to
fight them over something
that we had a genuine interest in we
could but we're not fighting them over
the ukraine that doesn't mean that this
is uh you know a fun cool
display
and that we should all be jazzed about
it but we're not fighting them over the
ukraine you know this is a
this is uh a real problem do you have
any updates on what's uh going on over
there so they held them uh off uh over
the night in the capitol pretty
impressive what the ukraine really is
yeah yeah kind of impressive to be
honest the death council i'm impressed
the death count is much higher with
russia at uh 3 500 troops killed than
200 captured and then ukrainians it's
about uh about 198 dead and the
thousands injured but they really held
them off overnight kind of losing
they're kind of being embarrassed
at the moment yeah at the moment losing
in terms of casualties of course right
yeah yeah interesting and zelinski's not
leaving he's refusing to leave he's
still posting videos right i'm not going
anywhere so
right but the the videos are it's
horrific it's it's very tough to watch
people who are civilians innocent
have done nothing
who are living their lives have to flee
a country
you
know i can all about i can just imagine
the sea of youtube comments
[Music]
it's actually good to watch that
you know
but the other the other side of it is
what are we gonna do i'm not going over
there
you're not going over there no no one's
going over there nobody i know is going
over there america is a country of
cowards
um you know as broad it was a fun uh
tweet where it's not all of us are
cowards but a lot
uh you know ted cruz you know there was
a storm in texas he like fled to cancun
there was a tweet you know um
you know our elected officials
uh you know when the when covet hits
they start insider trading
i mean you know nobody could care less
about this country
i mean giannis pop has brought up a
great point he's like if people if if
you said that people in america between
18 and 16 cannot leave the country they
would flee
they would all every
the vast majority of people would leave
and not defend the country
so it is inspiring to see the ukraine
uh do it yeah and there are refugees
hungary's taking in people you know
people are leaving but the people that
want to stay and defend yeah there's
families there's women and children and
then there's people and then there's
some bad ass ukrainian [ __ ] that are
staying
you know
but
i you know that are that are [ __ ]
i wonder i don't know what the outcome
is
it's destabilized the region forever now
for a very long time nobody from ukraine
is ever gonna forget this
i mean it's gonna be a real problem
and the the the same take here folks
is
that this is very sad
and it is not a positive development on
the world stage that's really it
it's not it's not to start screaming
about trump
or biden
or or anybody it's really
to just say hey
we should look at the way
that we
potentially contributed to a climate
that enabled
said things to happen whether it was
funding
nato
whatever it was
um
[Music]
but
there's there's there's nothing to do
here except
be upset and be like this sucks right
you know
it's
it's unfortunate that people are dying
now people in america
are so rotten to our core on both sides
of the political aisle and we have so
our humanity is almost all gone it's
almost been taken from us or really
truly and we have become
demons
in this country
political affiliation unimportant
and
what that has made us do is any
human tragedy that we see
we immediately
dig into it and try to like
make it someone's fault that we hate
and and excuse it
and not even look at
like the human cost and i say
look look
it's a psychotic impulse
it is a psychotic
impulse
it doesn't mean you can't have a
discussion about it
but it is a
psychotic
impulse it is an inhuman
impulse for the first thing you do
when you see like old women and children
being forced out of their homes and
fleeing to go hahaha i
tell you
there's something wrong with you
as a person if that's what you're doing
in the same way that when someone died a
cover that didn't get vaccinated and you
were celebrating that to an unhealthy
degree
that was also wrong that's my position
on it just be a human [ __ ] being if
you can
if you can if you possess
the ability to be a human
try
for five minutes
try to be a person
you know i know but the brand
for a second
just for a second
be a human being
is it possible
in this country
of
demons
real demons now
i mean when you
look around and see
the people
and you listen to the people we're in
hell
we're living in hell here
if this isn't hell i don't know what
could be hell
with the way that people just relate to
each other now
and
i for one
like
i i don't think the nato expansion
helped
i think we made an error in judgment
i think that
putin's not a guy that you're going to
be able to push around i think that u.s
policy
has not made this situation any better
i don't think that in in and of itself
excuses
or
justifies
in uh
and i'm not using because i know that
the real politic way to look at it is
obviously
it's not the justification
for
anything that anybody does
on the world stage is never morality
it's trade routes and ports and power
and i know all of that and i'm not
saying that i'm not a child
and i'm not saying that i don't
understand the rationale
behind the decision to invade the
ukraine
but when you when you look at it
from the perspective of a human being
and not
you know the perspective of like
somebody who's trying to like use this
as a springboard
to gain more
uh
eyeballs on what they're doing and say
just the most contrarian and
[ __ ] up [ __ ] imaginable and
you know well actually they're they're
right
they're right he's right to do that
um
when you look at it like that
you go no this is a brazen criminal act
where somebody's invading a country
uh unprovoked
by that country
um
and that should be
that should be roundly condemned
people shouldn't
people shouldn't be like yeah this is
cool
[ __ ] yeah
this shouldn't this isn't the thing
i know it's fun
to be a [ __ ] poster contrarian or
whatever
it's fun
it's uh edgy it makes you feel good
i guess it gives you power you don't
have in your life
to say something online that bothers
other people and i do it a lot i say all
kinds of [ __ ] the people are bothered
right now
very much they're very angry at what i'm
saying right now so i'm not saying that
that
is
not something that
should be
protected my only point is as a human
being it should give you a little pause
when you see the scenes
of
horror
emanating from that country you should
potentially
uh be given a little pause and you
should reflect a little bit
about
the human cost
of
something like this because it's not
nothing
it's not nothing when people are being
driven out of their homes
you know what i mean
china's stepping in now they're
restricting lending to russia china's
because china is now running the world
see america is a joke
but china is now coming in and now china
is saying because china's making money
china doesn't need this [ __ ]
china's in the lead
and china's going hey man we're winning
why are we doing that what are we doing
that for
you know like i'm i'm good
you know it's like
china's like we don't need you going
around destabilizing the world
we're killing it
we're like killing it it's like if
you're a big agent and one of your big
clients
is like
in every movie they are the hollywood it
girl and then they start posting about
palestine you go hey hey
we're winning now why why are we doing
this there'll be plenty of time to do
that
when they throw you out of hollywood and
you get fat and you're doing indies
light up the timeline with your opinions
but right now
cool it
just go to [ __ ] con and relax we got
a boat for you sit on the boat
and enjoy
so china is now getting involved to try
to well two chinese state-owned banks
will restrict financing for russian
commodity purchases suggesting there are
limits to beijing's support for moscow
as the kremlin confronts severe economic
sanctions
so offshore units of industrial and
commercial bank of china have stopped
issuing u.s dollar denominated letters
of credit for purchases of physical
russian commodities ready for export
while the bank of china has also limited
funding according to bloomberg
well i'm telling you right now
um
we got a real problem
on our hands
china's biggest banks hold billions of
russian assets beijing has also provided
moscow with tens of billions in funding
over the years
so that was pretty recent though i mean
this will come out later today we'll see
what happens this is awkward and i don't
like to have to do this because this is
something that
you know in order to
in order to do the show here and to earn
money
we live in kind of a morally compromised
world so every now and then we have to
do things that we don't necessarily love
um
you know and i
don't i don't love uh
having to per se
read some of the ads that i read right i
mean this is not something that i enjoy
doing but
i have to do it because in order to earn
money
uh
we have to do
certain things
it doesn't mean that we
love them
okay
that being said
the tim dillon show is sponsored by
gazprom
a multinational energy corporation
headquartered in the lotka center in
saint petersburg russia
in 2019 gazprom has done sales over 120
billion dollars it is the largest
publicly listed natural gas company in
the world and the largest company in
russia by revenue gazprom is excited to
be expanding heavily into the european
market offering natural gas natural gas
at a reasonable cost
gazprom is excited about the future of
energy and helping people live their
dreams
and meet their goals by using gazprom's
natural energy
if you want to buy energy from gazprom
go to gazprom.com
promo code tim
that is gasprom
russia's largest natural gas provider
gazprom
promo code
tim
to get 10 off your first purchase of
natural gas from russia
i don't love that
they are the leading provider of natural
gas and they bought ads on the show
well that's all i have to say about that
freshly
it is very hard to find a fast precooked
meal that isn't frozen tasteless or
highly processed food that doesn't have
to be fast food freshly offers quality
meals without the hard work
their meals ban are designed by
nutritionists cooked by chefs and
delivered fresh
other meal deliveries need to be prepped
and cooked but freshly is ready to eat
in three minutes no one wants to spend
an hour cooking dinner after a rough day
at work or an infuriating commute
at the end of a long day takeout doesn't
have to be your only option for an easy
dinner whether it's for you or the whole
family freshly gives you confidence
convenience flavor and nutrition
remember that time that freshly came
through in a pinch for you and me
and we were there and we were like what
uh you know and we were like we don't
want to do the go through a
drive-through and eat a big bowl of
blabla
and then you open the door and there was
a box outside and what was in it
delicious and fresh food that's right
and and how long did it take oh it's a
minute i mean minutes
and then we ate it
get delicious chef made nutrient packed
meals delivered straight to your door no
cooking required but is there a deal
there is a deal i mean here's my
question we know it's good we know by
buying it you're helping yourself
supporting the show and getting your uh
beach bod ready but is there a deal for
the people oh yeah just stop stressing
about dinner stop stressing about dinner
right now
freshly is offering our listeners ford i
gotta say the deal because if you say it
no one takes it seriously
stop stressing about dinner right now
freshly is offering our listeners 40
off your first two orders now literally
this is good and i'm i would recommend
this if you want to like eat better this
is no excuse freshly is no excuses
literally if you want to eat better it's
right there you have it there's no
excuse well i went out now well there
was you know there was butter in the
soot there's wheat in the bag
there's sugar in the dressing none of
that freshly
freshly is offering our list just 40 off
your first two orders when you go to
freshly.com tim dillon do it right now
freshly.com
tim dillon now
this winter upgrade your daily routine
with bespoke post and their new seasonal
lineup of must-have box of awesome
collections bespoke post partners with
small businesses and emerging brands
that bring you the most unique goods
every month you know box of awesome love
it don't you know box of awesome don't
you know box of awesome box of awesome
get excited because you know what it is
it's a box with all kinds of fun [ __ ] in
it
you you it's you get it and you give it
you can give it to people they open it
look at it you take a little quiz to see
what you're about and what you like from
cocktails to cozy threads to camping
gear essentials box of awesome has
collections for every part of your life
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up at box of awesome.com and enter
the code tim dillon at checkout that's
box of awesome.com i mean it's really
you get 80 worth of stuff
for 45
what was your favorite box of awesome
they sent me this like fishing knife
thing like a hunting fishing knife i
could like either carve a fish with or
whittle with had this really cool handle
on it that was my favorite thing that i
got really cool i couldn't believe it
was that uh inexpensive to to purchase
it was definitely far worth the value
they just sent me a dead possum with a
note that said kill yourself
go to box of awesome dot com and enter
the code tim dillon at checkout that's
box of awesome.com code tim dillon for
20 off your first box
wild
i mean i love it the knife in the terra
box is made by bare bones based in salt
lake city the weekender features metal
hardware reinforced frame quality
leather straps the damascus steel knife
is made by buck fair knives
the gut hook knife oh my god there's so
many knives
the american barbecue rub is made by the
great american spice co so here's what
we're trying to say here folks it's
really cool you get a lot of cool stuff
from american companies that make great
stuff
box of awesome everybody
tim dillon uh comedy.com for any of the
live dates
what is going on with this long island
housewife this is a fun
story out of long island new york
uh and it concerns our favorite things
long island
and real estate
and mental illness our third favorite
thing
can you bring that up paul
this uh
there's there's havoc in uh the long
island uh realtor community uh i mean if
you think kiev is bad
this woman's really causing issues here
this is a
long island woman who is going to
open houses in long island and refusing
to leave and threatening the other
buyers
and do i understand that correctly yeah
because it's a it's a taboo if you're at
an open house you don't sit on the
people's furniture you're not supposed
to sit on the people's furniture and
you're not really supposed to talk oh
really you're not supposed to
make
pronouncements loudly
you're supposed to have quiet
conversations
and then you know it's good
it's good form
to go and chat
outside if you bring your realtor to the
open house
you know you go outside and you have a
chat
you don't walk through and go this
kitchen
agents sometimes have to pay the bouncer
it's showings
you never know who's going to show up
when homes are open to the public so the
professionals have to keep cool and take
action
this is funny
there was a line for this showing a five
bedroom two and a half bathroom in three
village long island
i think we had like 32 sets of buyers
each with an agent easily 100 people it
was in a very desirable neighborhood a
great school district and the house had
lots of potential this was before covet
so we didn't have restrictions on how
many people could go in at one time
i had my associate joe working inside
the house trying to keep the flow going
i was outside meeting and greeting and
trying to keep up with everything pepe
try to keep everything peppy so nobody's
annoyed that they have to wait then joe
came out and pulled me aside and said
we've got a problem
there's a woman inside who is refusing
to leave
she has parked herself on the couch and
is telling people that this is her house
i went inside to find out what's going
on i can hear somebody with a raised
voice downstairs where the main living
area is
i go down and here's this woman
just sprawling there
one arm up
on the buck on the back of the back of
the couch
she was wearing like a moo moo
she reminded me of my mother people were
asking her are you the owner and she was
saying
no but i'm gonna be
i like it
i catch her answering a question about a
feature of the house
it was a teenage girl who was asking is
this the only bathroom on this floor
i hear this woman say yes it is
sweetheart
and it's not enough for you you're a
teenager you need more bathrooms you
should look somewhere else
i walked up and i said hi
are you okay
she said why would you ask me that
i explained that i work for the seller
normally people don't sit on the owner
church furniture during an open house
it's like using the bathroom you just
don't do it and she says
quote all these people are wasting their
time
and then she yells because i will outbid
you
i said my job is to make sure everyone
has an opportunity to see the house i
think you might be making some people
feel uncomfortable she says no i'm not
and then this guy who is also there for
the open house goes the hell you're not
why don't you stop flapping your mouth
long island
joe my associate stuck his head in the
door and i told him
not to let anyone else in
i had to look
i had to stop the can we make this
bigger is there any way we can make it a
little could you zoom in paul
thank you
uh i'm like taking an eye test here to
try to read no one on gas digital reads
anything
so there's no one's ever had to bring up
anything
to read
um
the funny thing is she never put in an
offer of course she didn't she was nuts
i like that i like the idea of a woman
sitting on the couch threatening people
and scaring them
and and then because she's because you
the thing about open house is you can't
really stop people from going in and
causing a real problem
and that there's something still
very democratic about that idea that
anybody can walk into any house that's
being sold and start an issue
and there's not much you can do about it
at this point you know
um
so i'm all for that i'm all for uh
open house problems
because realtors are their entire job is
to be fake nice
that's their entire
job
the most difficult thing about a
realtor's job
is being fake nice all the time to
everyone and realtors notoriously
hate
when
they have to
deviate from that psychopathic
personality trait
that they have that they've developed
where they just remain
fake nice
throughout all of their
daily interactions
and then when they go home they they
become
you know mr hyde again
and then the next day it's dr jekyll
hello
natural light indoor outdoor bedrooms
bathrooms isn't it nice and realtors
have to have their their their job is
made up only of small talk you will
never have a disc you'll never look at a
realtor and go i have cancer
everything
that you every interaction you have with
the realtor is small talk
and fake nice small talk so what happens
to these people
is when something interrupts that
fake
world of pleasantries
and niceties and meaningless inane
[ __ ]
it is the gravest
offense to them
like when anybody comes in from outside
to start a problem and there they
realize you're like i can't
i have to now
like show
real because this is upsetting me and
i'm angry and i want this to stop
but i'm also this person this creation
that that just wants to talk about
nonsense with these idiots
and someone's on the couch yelling and i
have to be stern and
angry and get her out of here and
they're just like [ __ ]
what do i do i have to be a human being
and they're like but my entire job
is to not be a person is to be a a
creation you know
a realtor is like um you know when
they're good at it
they're a prostitute kind of you know
like you know it's like you're getting
the girlfriend experience you're getting
someone you believe cares about you
and what you do and your life and family
oh isn't oh the yard they'll run oh
these kids in that yard but really what
they want to do is just make enough
money to bail their son out of
jail but they can't they can't tell you
that
because like anything else
all of these relationships exist
um out of necessity they are
things that need to happen and they just
should be nice
while they happen so i'm all for like
fat women
sitting on couches screaming
because there's nothing better than
seeing a nice person fake nice
nothing better than seeing like a fake
nice person have to like you can see
them almost they almost have like a
seizure they're like
what ha what are you doing like they
they're like losing they're like they're
like it's like at the end of cinderella
where they you know the carriage becomes
the pumpkin like they're reverting back
to their form and they're like oh what
are you
people people don't usually sit on the
furniture
people on youtube
and then you see them and they just
start melting and melting and
you know and again realtors for the most
part are not terribly bright
so they're not really good at problem
solving not the really high-end ones the
one i'm using now is phenomenal and
she's like a legend but the vast
majority of realtors are incredibly
stupid people who are very bad at
problem solving much like agents
the the vast majority of agents and
managers are incredibly stupid
and incredibly bad at their jobs these
are jobs that you can be very bad at
because the vast majority of people at
the job are also bad
and it's actually an agreed upon thing
that we're all gonna be bad at this
we're gonna be bad at it together
and that's why everybody can be bad at
it because there's almost an unspoken
rule unwritten rule
that
bad is good
and slightly above bad is great
so if you're a manager in the
entertainment business and you're not ab
you're not an abject failure you're the
best it's ever been
you're great and they will write books
about you and make movies about you
because the vast majority of people in
it are so incapable of performing the
menial day-to-day tasks of a job
that to be even slightly better than
that is to win the day like an agent to
be
slightly better than the general bad
is to be great
and that's kind of like realtors if you
were just slightly better
then the vast majority of like part-time
divorced housewife
uh people that are you know trying to
make a quick buck that have no idea what
they're talking about if you're even
slightly better than that
you're in
you become this
you can be really good at it you know
um
what what let's check let's check more
uh as we before we get out of here let's
check more about
um
this uh war because is it gonna end when
is it gonna end
you know i was reading sullivan's
article he was saying they're probably
gonna occupy as long as they want of
course should i sing a ukrainian folk
song
no i'm i'm very silly
there's there's not much i can do
but i want to help
patreon is not allowing people to donate
to the ukraine because they don't like
they there's a rule of patreon that you
can't donate money for people to like
buy weapons or something yeah yeah i
think i think that thing might have been
fake too but regardless they wouldn't
allow that i don't think anything wait
wait was it fake or not i i believe it
was yeah cause i don't think you can do
that on patreon i'm gonna double check
uh but i i think it would be a good idea
uh yes this is from
it says no you can't use patreon to buy
missiles for ukraine
patreon deleted the fun page without a
warning and a very difficult time for
ukraine and deleting the page patreon
said that the website of the
organization says that they use
contributions to finance and trained
military personnel and decided it's
harmful activities policy and banning it
um yeah i i i it was real i guess it was
real yeah
yeah they were trying to buy tanks
missiles
i mean again i don't want to
i feel like this is
i feel like this is insane
29 years of growth in harmony with our
clients
at the credit bank of moscow
moscow credit bank is best russian bank
according to world economic magazine
awards moscow credit bank has published
its code of conduct
and and applies esg principles at design
and procurement stages that you can read
moscow credit bank has 131 additional
offices in moscow and the moscow region
over 6 800 payment terminals and 1100
atms in moscow and moscow region if you
want to open an account at the credit
bank of moscow use promo code tim
for a little they'll sweeten it if you
make a nice little deal promo code tim
they'll kick you back a little interest
at credit bank of moscow
again 29 years of growth in perfect
harmony with our clients credit bank of
moscow
uh promo code tim
if you want to
open an account
that is uh mkrb
i'm sorry it's mkb.ru
mkb dot ru
credit bank of moscow
promo code tim
i feel conflicted
a little bit
by by doing this but not
but i but people have to understand
that the show needs a revenue stream
you get it right i get it we're running
a business here
i mean
i think credit bank of moscow probably
does a fine job
is there a is there a ukrainian folk
song that i can sing let's see here
because i i do want to do more than i'm
doing
and i feel that i'm i'm severely limited
by
many factors i can't really help
uh
i'm limited by many factors number one i
live in america number two i don't
really care
like i do but i you know
but i feel like if i were to sing a
ukrainian folk song
on the show
you might have people like
finally
understanding what's really what's
really at stake
this
is kind of a showing of solidarity it's
a statement it's not nothing
and i think that
i will certainly benefit
um
and i don't mean me i let me take that
back but i will benefit from
the knowing that i've done enough
you know because there's a lot of people
that right now going what should i do
should i donate should i and you should
do all of that but i think
let me sing a folk song on the show
paul i just sent you one okay so this is
a ukrainian folk song and the
translation is long live free ukraine
well that's awkward
okay
1.5 million views so this one must be a
popular one
oh my god this is gonna be so [ __ ]
hard
[ __ ]
this is so hard but
it's just not easy this language is not
easy
but i'm going to try
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
that was very difficult
uh
because it's a whole other language you
get it yeah people don't even understand
it's very it's not like a spanish where
you can kind of fake it
this is
right
it's a whole other thing it's a whole
other thing here
i'm gonna ask a serious question
do you think that helped
is there anyone out there that found
comfort in that
because you know the internet is it's
i mean it's global
there's a very good chance
that there are ukrainians watching this
show
and that just heard that
that now
are doing slightly better than they were
on a serious note if you are ukrainian
and you are watching this show
i'm [ __ ] sorry about what's going on
that is no reason to cancel the patreon
if you are a member of the patreon
it is five dollars a month and you get
four hours of content
a month
and if you're a rothschild member on the
higher tier you get an extra video
episode in addition to that so i don't
want
i'm very so i don't want that i'm not
one of these idiots in america cheering
this on i am aghast at this i truly
i truly feel bad for these people that
have to leave their country it is
repulsive to me i'm not a putin stan
i will tell you this
i don't believe
it is a sufficient reason
to not
continue to pay for the patreon if you
are a patreon subscriber
if it gets bad enough where i do feel
like you're justified in canceling i'll
let you know
but as of right now i think
should we do a thing where
here's no here's an idea i'm i'm i'm
serious about this do we do a thing
where if someone is from the ukraine
that enjoys and watches our show
and there's any way to communicate with
them
like can we give them our info
or an email for them to reach out
is there any way to like
open a channel of communication with
them
and have them like read an ad for us
is there any possible way for them to
read like
an advertisement for us there was a
ukrainian open miker that dm to me four
days ago
who uh wanted to come on the show
why why i mean why are you why is that
coming out now
do you i mean i don't even know if he
speaks that well of english i looked up
his videos it's all in uh did he did he
dm you in english he was very broken
though
i just don't understand why you would
bring that up now when that would have
been great we we should have had him on
why would you not bring that to me
um i i was flying i forgot
i mean that would have been great
right
is he still in new york well i also
don't know if maybe if he's uh maybe
he's a not a he's a bad egg he might be
a bad egg over there then you [ __ ] up
here stop trying to say he's like some
nazi i'm not saying he's the nazi
accusing him of being a nazi or
slandering him because you didn't bring
him to me and say he should be on the
show
where is he now uh let me let me check
my dms
see what he's up to get him right now
if you want a recording of the folk song
that i sang
we will be selling it
if it makes unless you can prove you are
in the ukraine
right now
if you can prove that we will give it to
you for half off
if you could prove that you are in the
ukraine right now during the war the
folk song i sang
will be given to you a half off
we got to reach out to these people ben
this is absurd
that you didn't bring this to my
attention ben really doesn't do his job
this is very interesting ben really
doesn't do his job and
it's now becoming more and more apparent
to everybody
that ben has been you know
really coasting here he coasts and all
he does is complain that he has to
travel and him and his wife can't get
drunk
all they want to do is get drunk and go
follow colin moricao around
i'm trying to fight he's probably dead
ben
he wanted to come on the show as the
last thing he could [ __ ] do
to just
tell everybody what was up i'm sure he
had a lot of nice things to say about me
and my comedy and how it's impacted him
before he was killed by russia and you
ruined that you ruined the chance for
this man
as his last earthly act to come on the
show and tell me that i
it was a great influence on him and to
keep doing what i'm doing right before
this man dropped dead
well at the time also i thought we were
having a mark on for so i just
completely forgot we always need a
backup that's true
should have kept him on standby and you
don't even have his message i'm looking
for it uh it's amazing to me the lack of
prep
the lack of respect that this guy has
for this show every week he does less
can you imagine
i'm scro all my dms are people
threatening to kill me i'm trying to
find and there should be more
i mean
the guy gets a message i found him here
okay here he is right there call him
hi ben i am from ukraine comedian have
five subs on twitter also if you need
any info i can connect you with
competent people for tim dillon's show
about war
we're calling him right now
he's dead
it's 8 30 there he should
be awake he's dead you killed him
i feel terrible about you killing this
person
i'm watching his story right now
dude this is like [ __ ]
hopefully this dude's okay
if not we know we have to blame ben
avery
his name is
vladislav or something
i'm following him back i'm messaging him
hey man reach back out when
you can hope you're
okay this is tim
well there you have it ben avery uh
a guy wants to come on the show i mean
do you feel a little ashamed
yeah i should have had him as backup
well that's not even for the show it's
like this guy
wants to get out information from a war
zone on a major podcast platform and you
ignore him well i mean it's it's a
little absurd is it no it is
i mean it's a pretty big [ __ ] up but
you're people can have your head for
that you're a large media figure and you
could be feeding us misinformation he
could be ben now what you're doing is
you're trying to justify the fact that
you did not even bring this to me as an
option here you're you're you're trying
to what you're trying to keep me from
misinformation
i mean what's going on here
this is insane
is that that that's your act now you're
trying to protect me from misinformation
you said i'm supposed to protect the
show
yeah
you're supposed to protect the show by
not letting us
make bad decisions
or
not letting episodes
come out late or something but what
you're supposed to do is when somebody
reaches out from a volatile active war
zone and wants to come on this show and
tell me that i'm a genius before they're
killed
and you don't i
i
i'm i i i'm incensed at you right now i
truly cannot believe
you did this
this was this guy's dying wish to tell
me that i was the greatest comedian
that he's ever seen
before he was killed in an invasion and
you ignore him
you didn't even respond back to him dude
i mean um
should you want to apologize to him yeah
i'll say his at i'll apologize no don't
say his ass okay okay
we want to keep it private vladislav i'm
very sorry for what i did i should have
reached back to you and kept you on
standby because vladislav i wish ben was
killed by the russians and not you
i hate ben
another [ __ ] up from ben avery everybody
that's what this show can count on a guy
from an active war zone wants to update
us and by the way we're kidding here
hopefully he's okay hopefully yeah we
hope he's okay we hope the guy's okay i
mean
i hope open micros aren't being drafted
i mean
you really want to lose
but hopefully he'll be okay
but this is [ __ ]
it's [ __ ]
it's sad it's tragic tragic and you are
tragic for not allowing this person
to come on this show
so i mean
again
if
if you like
if you like um
people being killed in the ukraine
ben avery is your boy
no
pat ben avery is good if you are a
ukrainian that doesn't like this war
maybe go give him a piece of your mind
that ben avery is good
if you are a ukrainian
who is against the war
perhaps ben avery is good should hear
from you i don't know i'm just saying
perhaps he should hear from you
that's all i'm saying
i think you have to take some
responsibility for your actions in these
situations
people are in in deep trouble and
they're trying to reach out
you know
and hopefully
this will be balanced out by the fact
that i sang that folk song
and it's i i don't know
it's gonna be tough to balance the
scales here but i think i did a
pretty phenomenal job
for having never spoke
ukrainian
you know only a few more shows left on
this hellish tour at the end we're
taping a special in denver what what do
we got left here god help us and save us
uh so tonight you'll be in albany when
this comes out who cares uh concord new
hampshire uh tomorrow
sold out uh brea improv buy tickets for
brayer folks it's in anaheim it's a dump
uh yeah it's in brea it's march 11th
12th 13th come on in uh toronto march
16th that's right get tickets to that a
lot of them have sold out but get some
baltimore on the 18th
philadelphia tickets there's a shitload
of tickets available to baltimore
philly's got a few left yeah the parks
casino march 19th in philly uh nashville
march 24th nashville ryman gonna be a
great show tickets still available grab
them uh uh denver march 26 two shows two
shows denver march 26th
taping of the special
then you go to glasgow on march 30th
glasgow get tickets dublin get tickets
london get tickets
and then that's it that's the first week
of april then that's the end of the show
folks and then maybe we don't know if
we're gonna do this maybe in april we do
dallas and houston oh nice
and cleveland
maybe three or four more we don't know
before the special comes out
timdelacomedy.com for all tickets
any lasting apologies to the people of
ukraine for what you've done to them
um i mean i don't know if
no we're i'm being we're being deadly
syria
i'm i support deadliest i stand with
ukrainian people it's a tragedy what's
going on i feel i feel sorry for this
guy
i could come up with a million excuses
but
there's no excuse i did fail i i failed
miserably here with this guy
i'm
i'm not gonna go into any excuses i have
plenty some are somewhat justified but
i
vladislav if you're listening i'm very
sorry reach out to me i'll try to do
something for you i don't know what that
is
but i'll try to help you out in any way
i can
vladislav
yet
what's nyet no
i this is tim dillon i'm sorry my ad guy
really [ __ ] up
but
we're here to talk about mud water which
is a coffee alternative
and it has four active genetic mushrooms
with ayurvedic herbs with one seventh
the caffeine as a cup of coffee you get
the energy without the anxiety jitters
or the crash of coffee each ingredient
was adapted uh and added for a purpose
you get cacao and chai from mood and a
micro dose of caffeine lion's mane
for alertness cordyceps to help support
physical performance chaga and rishi to
support your immune system turmeric for
soreness and cinnamon for antioxidants
mud water is whole30 approved 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten-free vegan and
kosher certified
uh i love mud water i love it with um
honey mud water has launched a new
evening ritual the perfect blend a
non-caffeinated tea that promotes
relaxation and rest because the best
morning ritual starts the night before
go to
mudwater.com support the show and use
promo code tim
for five dollars off relationships take
work
a lot of us will drop anything or go
help someone we care about we'll go out
of our way to treat other people well
but how often do we give ourselves the
same treatment this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you to
take care of your most important
relationship the one you have with
yourself whether it's hitting the gym
making time for a haircut or even trying
therapy you are your greatest asset so
invest the time and effort into yourself
like you do for other people better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try to see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this ponce
this podcast
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and tim dylan show listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.comd
that's betterhelp.com tim day that's
r h e l p dot com slash tim tang i love
better help
because sometimes i'm sad
and i log on to the internet
and someone says you're worth it
i think vladislav is calling me oh get
get them on here
uh hello vladislav stay rolling on this
paul
how are you this is tim dillon i'm a
comedian from america
how are you
let me ask you is there a way that we
can talk to you on like skype or
something let me
talk to you for a minute ben all right
we are here with vladislav who is a
ukrainian comedian dude
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk with us how are you doing over
there
i'm doing fine currently i am
at the shelter
in kiev and i am trying to find my way
to get guns get west's get helmets
and uh
share them with my friends with my
family so everyone is armed because in
kiev now if you are not uh like uh armed
samurai you're a [ __ ] no one
right or nobody
now
how have
how quickly this seemed to happen very
quickly
where you guys declared martial law
and you you told me that you guys are
trying to raise money and trying to find
weapons and trying to just basically
help the troops as best that you can
yes we are trying to help the troops as
best as we can i
had my uh
i have my own channel and we just
uh
live streaming for 15 minutes uh 12 to
20 minutes ago before just before we
talk and we raised a crazy amount of
money and we will buy and uh
like crazy gun equipment and this is
very good because we need equipment for
snipers and snipers are very cool
in uh city combat because we are now
leading to city combat uh fights because
most of the uh
in the two
two days two days that we have uh
our combat
we fought on the border uh we fought uh
on uh
rivers and now uh we need to
arm up uh even more
now the were you guys surprised that
this happened or were you guys expecting
it because a lot of people were thinking
that putin was bluffing
did you guys think he was bluffing or
did you guys think this was gonna go
down
uh we were ready for uh any scenarios
that could happen but ukrainians were
always ready for putin to invade because
russia have had invaded ukraine many
many many times we had a whole other
more in
1933
uh
and it was insane everybody uh saying
like
not everybody because but a lot of
russian propaganda is like we are
brothers and uh that's all but as it's
not like that even a little bit uh we
were uh pretty much
always concerned about uh military
invasion but you
you can't prepare yourself for for a
military invasion because it's right
it's spark
how is the feeling about russia
obviously now it's not good but before
this
aren't you like a lot of people in
russia have family in ukraine
you guys are you're there's certainly a
lot of
you know
connections between the two countries
right i mean
what was the feeling about russia
pre-invasion was it
were do you have family in russia you
have friends in russia or because i know
many people in russia have family in
ukraine
is is that the situation or is that not
the case
families can't hate each other if you
know
so oh oh i know
oh i know
oh i know very well that they can
we also we
hate our
own families in ukraine and if our
family are in russia we hate them even
more and
i agree i hate my own family in long
island and they're they're very close to
me
um
what do you think the outcome putin
wants you think he wants a regime change
he wants to put in a puppet
government that that will basically
carry out his will that seems to be what
he wants
he is crazy he wanted to do a fast
blitzkrieg
but it's like
he has
no connection with the world because we
have
not
much but we have
uh cool cool toys we have and loads we
have stingers and he's just crazy he's
just oh i have a helicopter with uh uh
like uh flying
descent i don't know how they called
like marines marines and i will
land
that helicopter and helicopter just
flies and we just like
there's no helicopter and he thought
yeah
24 times is that he is like oh i will
send them my
tanks tanks are going and tanks are
burning up all the tanks are burning up
right now he thought the military was
gonna fold quicker than it did but you
guys
have been showing that it's not gonna be
easy
you are not making it easy yeah
because uh if we lose then it's gonna be
worse for a long and long time and if
you win it's gonna be uh
gonna be the end of russia and end of
putin because he has no
real
way
how how he will gonna end this fight for
him to be
like the winning the winning point he
has he he lost all the
uh
all the support from the world
even in we had like pro russia europe
countries like uh hungary
and like germany and even they are
promoting that then russia from swift no
yeah now so let me ask you a question
you're a comedian
in the uk yes i mean i'm sorry in uh in
the ukraine
and
what is now you're a political comedian
so you do jokes about politics and stuff
also
yeah of course also not only but
sometimes
um
how is that there what is what is the
comedy scene like in the ukraine
for a guy like you
uh to do comedy what has that been like
comedy scene have been changed in the
past two years
very significant
significantly because uh our standup was
born like maybe in
2012
and also
there are russian standard and russian
standard is like a cargo cult of an
american stand-up it's just like stupid
it's just stupid and uh
also
they can't say that
they don't they don't don't have like
feelings they're just
jokes no they have good comedians but
that's like about not we can't we can't
relate to that we can't feel about that
we don't have nothing and uh we are in
ukraine have a lot of ukrainian speaking
comedians and we have a lot of
russian-speaking comedians and is there
a tendency for the past two years that
russian-speaking comedians are turning
themselves into ukrainian-speaking
comedians because everyone in ukraine
knows ukrainian just
uh because of a russian occupation a lot
of ukrainians also know russia yeah it's
it's like a stupidly cool
between
uh was stupidly cool right between uh
some ukrainian comedians to just like uh
hell away uh through the to the moscow
moscow is like uh uh
it's like a los angeles for a stupid
ukrainian comedian and then we figured
out
we figured out that los angeles for a
smart comedian who like money is ukraine
in kiev and right
when we started doing stand-up in
ukrainian people we saw that people
really like us and people don't hate us
and you can cheat on ukrainians and you
can [ __ ] on russians and you can [ __ ] on
americans you can [ __ ] on everything
people relate to that people uh have fun
with it people will donate you money
people will love you we have also uh we
have a slightly uh similar uh
like strategy
as you
uh in ukraine yeah like compassion we
have youtube channels we have instagram
we have twitter and people use it people
use it because it's ukrainian if we will
be a russian speaking ukrainians yeah
people will will think that we
are leading like our way to moscow that
we can we can we plug your social media
on our show like
can we get you more followers is that a
good idea right now or do you want to
keep more of a low profile
yes it's a it's a good idea i post
sometimes uh my native pictures
it's not wait
if you want me
that's interesting if
if you uh if you want i can uh
uh message you i can message you uh that
russian
dead russians
oh okay
well and also naked picture we'll take
both we'll take naked pictures and dead
russians if you'd like and we will uh
we'll put them on our patreon
but now are you go are you leave you're
not nobody's leaving nobody's fleeing
you're staying there
no also there are cowards there are
women's iraq kids they gotta go
uh
yeah they gotta go why not everybody has
uh it's how do you feel about the
president zielenski he seems to be doing
a good job
man first we thought that
the country went crazy they elected the
low-grade comedian but very popular i
think that like you will elect i don't
know who who's who's bad like you
you will elect uh the guys that uh
stole jokes uh carlos mancilla
carlos
he was one actor he was uh very talented
he was like very cool but uh comedy was
about like uh like my aunt and not uh
like he was it was uh more
uh for the people right it was like not
for sure
but you can't blame him for that because
there was pretty much no other coming
ukraine
yeah and we we as uh stand-up comedians
we
thought that this guy is crazy and we
saw the country when went insane that he
they just like stupid jokes and now he's
[ __ ] i don't know
he's standing uh biden uh
biden say hey
would you like to come to us we can
get you out of the country and he's like
no i will [ __ ] die here
yeah that that by the way i respect the
hell out of that and uh
i'm trying to think of an american
equivalent to that uh there ain't uh our
our people would be on a plane
they would be on a jet uh real quickly
um
i really hope that you guys stay oh yeah
he
also i want to uh
say that zelansky [ __ ] zero child
yes well that's good
that's very positive and we yeah we
appreciate that that also
that also may be why your country is
being invaded
it is a catch-22 you know one of those
you know unfortunately who are your
favorite comedians in the ukraine from
america
uh my favorite comedians in ukraine was
america okay so you should check
channel stracadopa is our channel it's
only in ukrainian but it's uh
uh fine you also should check your
taylor he has uh
his own uh special on divorce.com you
should check andre
you should check uh
i don't know who yeah
plug all those people on your social
media because we're never going to be
able to spell those names
um
what do you guys like american comedy
yeah of course we like a lot of american
comedy and we
i watch your shows i watch uh a lot of
uh i don't know stupid american [ __ ] i
sometimes hate something okay
just we have two cultures we have
ukrainian culture we have american
culture sometimes we
force ourselves to not watch russian
culture because it's stupid
you just watch one russian comedian and
also youtube
next video suggest you a war movie and
you're like [ __ ] it
right half of the youtube russian
youtube is war movies about oh how it
was in 44.
what is the plan now the plan is just to
hold off
russian forces as much as you can
and basically obviously keep raising
money
and
hopefully
you know with enough pressure on putin
and people you know countries like china
now coming out and you know a lot of
sanctions happening that he would you
know eventually he'll give this up
yeah we will push we will push the
things you
we will push the things as long as we
are winning because for
now we are winning
uh
we was very happy with the ukrainian uh
people uh raising patreon for their save
life in ua it was the number one patient
in the world they gathered for well i
don't
know thousand people i don't like that
because we're we're like the number two
show on patreon and i gotta be honest
with you i worked a lot harder than
these uh ukrainians raising the money
we've got a lot more content they don't
have any content on that patreon so to
me that's a little ridiculous but i do
respect that
tell us
where to follow you and where to donate
because i we want to donate money and i
want to have all my fans that can and
want to donate money how do we follow
you
okay
uh you uh can donate money uh at save
life uh one word save life dot in dot ua
it's a very good organization they
are very nice they have a lot of uh
paypal they have everything they have
bitcoin they have yes we'll put that in
the
description of the episode
yes also we have a national uh ukraine
band
uh which is a national ukraine bank
is have an eye ban long a ban and you
can donate to that
also i can uh email you my card number
and card number for like small groups
yeah i will i will i will personally
donate
five thousand dollars to you
if you give me a way to do that
if you give me a way to do that
we will figure it out we'll figure it
out i will absolutely personally donate
that
uh to you
uh and it's not a lot of money but it's
enough money where hopefully that can
help a little bit
okay we will send you focus
uh afterwards what'd you say
oh you will send your photos yeah no and
videos well for 5 000 you have to do
videos as well but the no i want to i
want to help you yeah i mean it's five
grand but i want to help you as much as
i can
um
you know you guys it's inspiring [ __ ] to
see
your uh comedian
um if someone invaded america
to kill
all of us
uh the comedians would be helping them
so it's nice that you guys are
fighting for your own country
standing up where can we find you on
social media
you can find me at uh
uh instagram.com vladkapizza
okay we're gonna put that in the link in
description too i mean it's amazing you
don't fit the look
yeah sorry you can also find me on
twitter vlad kapitz because twitter are
popular between
ukrainian politics and ukrainian
and it's not very popular
and it's popular uh worldwide so right
that's pretty much how i uh found you
and found a lot of people yes
yeah it's very interesting you look like
you're from california i mean i don't
know what ukrainians look like but
you look like you should be on the show
euphoria this was not what we were
expecting
at all i mean it's a hell you look like
you're like a tick tocker who lives in
hollywood but
we are really sorry that this shit's
going down and we're really gonna try to
help as much as we can in terms of
donating money telling our people to
donate money and
if listen hopefully this [ __ ] ends
and you come to america we'll we'll get
you on some shows
yes it will be pretty much fun and i
think that uh when uh
this [ __ ] will end you will come to
ukraine and do some shows because uh
people are buying if people are buying
tickets to louisike
yes no i i would i would love
find a way to promote you because we
have uh also a promotion going on i
think uh
and it will be cool and it is uh
uh one having fun
and watching cool content and uh getting
inspired and
it's it's one uh
one of the reasons to uh have a health
uh gun in your hands
yes yes i i i believe that's a 100
percent true it's something to fight for
it's something to fight for warren and
dostoyevsky and we don't like it right i
no it's something to fight for that is
literally what you fight for your
quality of life and to have a free
country and have freedom you know and
dude i would be very very excited to
perform in the ukraine unless russia
pays me more
[Laughter]
i mean no i'm kidding dude i i want to
thank you that we we we did this whole
bit about you because you sent ben a
message and and ben didn't answer it and
i screamed at him on the show and we
were like this guy's probably dead
and i can't believe you didn't answer
his message and it's a whole bit and
we're so happy that you're okay
your friends are okay
and i'm hoping that everybody makes this
it makes it out of this
uh and and you know we could all
[ __ ] look back at this and like you
know
i'm hoping that's the case you know and
like
you know any support yeah
in case if i die i will uh text a ban uh
a list of uh second-hand comedians for
your show yeah please we really
appreciate that
um
no we really appreciate that i think
you'll be fine stay safe you know
obviously do what you guys got to do
over there um
and we really appreciate you taking the
time because we know it's not [ __ ]
easy
we're gonna put together
all of those links in our episode we're
gonna put them on our instagram we're
gonna put them on our twitter for people
to donate
help you out
if they can
and um keep keep in contact with us man
keep letting us know like what's going
on and and ways that we can help
okay uh also i wanted to say slavo
ukrainian it's like uh glory to america
and the response is uh heroin
can you say that
what is it
what does that mean
that means
glory for the heroes
yes hitorium slava glory
glory for the heroes and i i think you
putin really went in there thinking it
was going to be an overnight thing
he thought it was going to be a lot
easier than it's been you guys have
shown him that it's not going to be that
easy you're fighting for your home your
culture your religion your heritage
whatever you're fighting for the freedom
to live and it's an inspiring thing
and there's there's there's people in my
country that don't respect it because
they're mentally ill we have many
mentally ill people here but people that
are human beings the few of us that are
still left are watching it looking at it
going it's [ __ ] inspiring
and um
i i really appreciate this now i mean
i mean the awkward thing is he's not in
ukraine he's not even ukrainian this is
a guy we hired who's in l.a
he's too good-looking he's behind his
sound stage i mean this is a green
screen but i still think it it still
feels good right oh yeah it still helps
i think this still matters
um
yeah i can show you uh bottles of
ukrainian beer
cocktail for sure well don't have too
much fun over there
and um
listen i mean it may be inappropriate
but i still think it's a it's a it's a
you know we've got merge dropping it's a
great time to get some hoodies over
there it's not horrible all right
vladislav
thank you so much you're an awesome dude
man thank you very much
thank you very much tim